- [Narrator] This is
Picasso, a Senegalese parrot.
(gentle instrumental music)
Due to their popularity,
they are one of the most heavily
trapped birds in the world.
Spread throughout Western Africa,
they live in open woodlands and savannas
and feed on fruit, seeds, buds
and occasionally crop items.
Senegalese parrots are
only about nine inches long
and weigh up to six ounces.
They may be small in size,
but they're a gregarious bunch
with lively, energetic personalities.
Their dark gray faces are complemented
by green and yellow
plumage across their body.
Senegalese parrots are
incredibly popular pets,
which has made the
trade, import and export
of wild-caught parrots illegal.
This is the Senegalese parrot.